Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier,
and welcome to "Baldi's Basics Kickstarter Field Trip."
Now, this is a demo for the Kickstarter
that is going to make an official "Baldi's Basics in Education and Learning" game!
God, I love the UMpas of this song here!
So this is--uhh--apparently more of a proof of concept,
but we're going on a field trip, which is always fun,
but I must survive while also trying to score as high as possible,
"The better your score, the better your rewards".
"The highest scores will even get you permanent buffs that last for the rest of your game"
...which I'm assuming is gonna end as soon as I die,
which is gonna be a lot.
Maybe.
Any description of this is probably gonna pale in comparison to the actual game, so- oh.
Oh!
[Quietly chuckles]
I'm sorry.
[Laughs]
My curiosity often gets the better of me,
and I apologize for that.
So there's nothing else?
Ye--Oh.
Oh--[Mark laughs]
Ooh, I don't like that!
No, somethin' doesn't feel right about what I'm seeing right there,
so I'm just gonna skedaddle over here and see if there's something else-
er, okay, well.
[Mark breathes]
Is it-
OOOOOOOOHHHHH.
"No, seriously, that's it".
Oh..
"STOP! There's nothing else!"
So says you!
"You'll regret this..."
I don't think I will!
[Principal] "No breaking the fourth wall in the halls."
I'm sorry...
What are you gonna do about it?
Okay, alright then.
Well, I'm just gonna back away slowly.
Ooh.
It's one-way walls of text.
Wait, is the same thing behind the other one, too?
Or is there anything behind the other one?
I'm sorry I tried to explore anything!
[Oof sound effect]
Ooh, okay, oof.
OOF.
Okay!
[Baldi] "Let's go camping!"
Oh, I hate your mouth.
I don't often say that to someone as soon as I meet them,
but I hate your mouth.
Also, is that weed on the ground, what is that?
Nice ballsack of a cloud over there.
Okay, well, you know, how 'bout...
Ooh, how 'bout we don't?
Oh.
Ah.
UM.
Teacher?
I don't think I'm supposed to be
OH.
UHHH.
MMMM.
AHOHUM.
I UH...
I didn't mean to do this, teach.
if you could believe me?
I...
[Principal] "No breaking the fourth wall in the halls."
I DIDN'T MEAN IT.
LOOK, I DIDN'T MEAN IT!
I just got curious!
You've never been curious-
[Principal] "No breaking the fourth wall in halls."
Okay.
Can  I come...?
Ho!
AHHHHH
Oh, you silly bitch!
Huhuhuhuhuh.
Oh.
My energy meter is still there.
Much teeny-tinier, but it's still there.
Ookay, alright, I'm gonna move on then.
[Baldi] "Let's go camping!"
You gonna say that every time?
[Mark in a poor Baldi voice] Let's...
[Normal voice] Alright.
Y'know, what, you make a compelling argument, Baldi.
[Baldi] "Alright, all set!"
"I'll go set up the bear traps!"
"I want you to keep the fire going!"
"Go out into the woods and collect fire wood."
"Then, bring it back to re-fuel the fiiiiiiiiire!"
"The bigger the fire is, the more points you'll earn!"
[Mark nervously cheers]
[Baldi] "Alright, go for it!"
[Mark cheers again]
Oh!
[Mark cheers]
This reminds me of a DOOM mod, oddly enough.
A really terrifying DOOM mod.
Oh.
I got a stick!
I got one, two, three sticks!
I don't like the sound of whatever that is.
[Baldi voiceover] "WOW!"
WOW indeed.
I live to please...
...Mr. Bald Man.
What is that?
Is that a bear trap?
Should I not touch that or should I-
I'm gonna absolutely touch that.
[Quiet metal clank]
YOWCH!
My dingle donger!
Okay, there we go.
Where'd that stick go?
I guess I got it, and I'm gonna bring the stick back.
That was the objective that was given to me.
Okay, got stick.
I got a stick, teach!
[Distant howl]
Oh, that's a pleasant sound.
Hm.
Well, if the only danger in here is sticks and bear traps,
I think I'm gonna be okay.
Uh oh.
Better skedaddly daddle back here.
So what am I uh,
[Baldi voiceover] "WOW!"
WOW, I know, right?
Pretty impressive teach, huh?
I'm a pretty cool, happenin' student.
And did you have to set so many bear traps?
You know I just wanted to...
I just wanted to run by you the idea of a bit too much bear trap here.
Maybe.
I really don't like the way that...
the crickets know how close I am to death.
Uh-oh.
I'm real slow now.
Oh! It's heavy. Carrying sticks is...
Uh-oh.
I don't have any sprint, so that's not good.
[Mark mumbles under his breath]
I hope I get here in time
So far...
[Baldi voiceover]
WOW!
Wow! I know, that was a lot of points
It sure was a lot. What happens when I run out?
I only got so much time left.
But I guess, that's good though-
I mean, would Baldi be mad at me if I - if I didn't...
Keep the fire going?
[Grumble]
[Baldi & Mark]
Wow!
I know right, Baldi?
I need some more sticks.
[Music plays]
Oh!
Hey! 'Wow-time, you won!''
'This is where you get great rewards based on your-'
[Ethreal Music]
Uh-huh
Oh.
Let's go again!
[Baldi in the background]: "Fiiiiiire." [Mark]: Okay.
I'm just...
[Baldi: "The bigger the fire is, the more points you'll earn."]
I'm not [Baldi: "Alright!"] listenin' to you, teach!
[Baldi: "Go for it!"]
I'm going to go eat some candy and do some drugs out in the woods.
You can't stop me!
I'm a b--I'm a rebel! You can't stop me.
I'm going to see what's at the edge of the world over here..
I got two sticks, you know what I'm going to do with two sticks.
Alright, so I can't go off the map here.
[Crickets]
There got to be something in these woods, right?
[Crickets continue]
[Smacking sound, getting progressively louder]
Woah! Hey! Woah! Teach! Woah! Baldi! Hey! Woah.
Hey. Come on now
[Slapping getting louder]
Hey, Baldi. B- Baldi. B- Baldi!
[Slapping gets even louder]
BALDI!
Baldi! Wait! Woah! Hey!
[Jumpscare static noise]
Was that?
Was that necessary?
Was that nec- Was that nece-ss-ary?
What if I get him to walk into a bear trap, huh?
What if I do that?
Huh?
[Smacking noise starts]
What if you hit a bear trap?
Huh?
Stupid idiot.
Baldi's bitch!
Come here you... Get in the bear...
Get in the... GET IN THE BEAR--
[Jumpscare static noise]
He didn't get into the bear trap.
Oh, I'm real slow, teach.
I got six sticks.
I got six sticks, teacher. I can count to six because your math that helped me learn how to count!
Then I'm gonna go adventuring out in the woods.
It seems as if this would give me more time.
[Baldi in disstance]
Wow!
Wow! I know, teach. I know. I'm pretty goddamn impressive.
I got a big ol' throbbing brain.
That's able to think of stuff and also math!
I'm able to think of math! I'm not able to do math, but I'm able to think of it!
Real hard!
Whelp.  [Smacking] Maybe if I throw sticks at him.
Oh, I just dropped my sticks.
My sticks. My sticks! I'm ruined!
All my sticks! Baldi, please, let's talk about this. Hang on, wait, baby, Baldi, baby, Baldi! [Jumpscare static noise]
Whoa!
That was closer than I thought you'd be
Okay
I think that's it.
I don't think that there's anything else here...
I mean I could try to go out as far as I can here
and see what's in the depths of hell, in the
Infinite sky box that is this zone.
I guess I'm doing that.
Cuz what better do I have to do with my time?
[thud noise]
sorRY
Yepperoni, still goin'
Woop-i-dee-doo-doo
Alright. Oh--!
No, still going.
I thought I hit a wall there.
Alright
Au revoir!
Au revoir
Baldi, bitch.
I'm going awa--I'm going--
I dunno where that bus was going, but heading to the woods on foot.
You--you take the bus, I'll walk
We'll see who beats there.
*Whut*
uh--who there.
We'll see who beats who there.
Aup!
And it just faded away
I am now lost in the void I would never find my way back.
Alright, with nothing else to do, I guess I'm just going to go for the high score. [Baldi: Let's go camping!]
Good boy, Baldi.
[Baldi: Alright, all set! I'll go set the bear traps]
[Mark mocking Baldi's words as he moves away]
[Mark, imitating Baldi] I'm going for it.
Gotta get back
I'm gonna get a newww record
Okay, don't - don't die yet!
I got seven
I got eight sticks!
and a lot of sprint! okay, sprint's good!
a bam!
[Baldi in the background: Wow!]
Mark: WOoOW, I know, Baldi!
You're pretty goddamn impressed from wherever the hell you are in the woods
Let me tell ya something else that's impressive about me.
My kung fu, my huuuge dick, and then my my-uh my my,
nothin' nothin' I got nothin' else impressive besides those features.
Oh there's no sticks left! There's no sticks, I got all the easy sticks!
ah!
Oh, oh it was not a full go. It was not a full go, was it? Oh ten seconds ah I gotta go! I gotta book it baby!
gimme GIMME the god- ahhh shitty ticky sticks! [Smacking sound, progressively louder] Ah where hey woah hey woah times up!
OH TIME WAS UuUUp??
Time was up!
Time was uppppp.
Well, damn you.
Alright, I'm gonna get those sticks
[Mumbles] and you're (Baldi) gonna get the fire going to so I can roast your corpse over it when I get back.
hu hu hu
That's me, Baldi The Cannibal!
If I'm even human
hu hu hu
Alright, I've got a LOAD of sticks,
a big BUNDLE of sticks,
Got seven!
Not as many as I would like
Ohh, and I'm out of sprint.
Ooo
URGHH
I might get Baldi'd!
[Roblox "OOF" noise]
Maybe it 'twas more risky than I assumed.
OHHH
WAIT
[Fast paced smacking]
OH NO WAIT NO
[Jumpscare static sound]
Ahh
I didn't know that's how you did that,
why did you, were you in the fire the whole time?
That just raises more questions about "why?" and "how?" and what you were doing in the fire.
I'm gonna have nine sticks, maybe, if I can get, okay this is gonna be a close one.
Hope I don't see the DEVIL getting summoned, I've got nine sticks!
That's gotta be some kind of a record!
[German voiceover]: NEIN
[Baldi voiceover]:
Wow!
[Baldi and Mark]:
Woww
Pretty good, right guys?
Pretty good, I know, right?
Wow one stick!
Wonder if you get so many sticks in there if the-the bugs start chirping higher and higher, exponentially higher frequency until they eventually all explode?
and then the woods are engulfed in flames.
So close
don't kill me!
Ha-booski
[Baldi]:
Wow!
Alright, wow indeed
I'm pretty good
yeah I'm pretty good
I would get some cool rewards
Ok so that is the Baldi's Basics Kickstarter Field Trip Demo
If you guys want to play for yourself try to beat my high score of 51,000
but right now
The developer of Baldi's Basics is trying to raise money to develop a full version of the game
And I don't know what a full version of the game is gonna be like,
but I imagine it's going to be a kind of encompassing all aspects of School, in terms of "education and learning."
So, where the first Baldi's Basic was probably just about math, the other one would have
Geography, field trips, Recess. All this good stuff.
But then again, I don't know. Check out the Kickstarter, I'll provide a link down in the description below.
Thank you everybody so much for watching and as always,
I'll see YOU,
in the next video!
Buh-bye!
[Rapid slapping, jumpscare static noise]